and that actually brings us to another
story here
in the united states
not just florida anymore we're talking
about the entire country the number of
children being hospitalized for covid
has hit a new record
and what's really disturbing too is that
even though we have a record number of
children
hospitalized recovered they still only
make up 2.4 percent
of covered hospitalizations
so more kids than ever but because we
also have more people than ever
this is what we have um
stories out on sunday telling us that
over in uh
texas i believe it was
they're doing what new york had to do in
the early days of the pandemic and
they're setting up hospital beds
in the parking garage it was either
texas or mississippi i forget oh but
mississippi actually did have an 8th
grader
die of covid
an 8th grader 13 14 years old
eligible for the vaccine but had not
received it as far as we know died from
covid
because there was no safe way to send
all these kids back to school
and for the record yes
under 18 hospitalizations are at a
record high you know what else is going
up
the 19 through 29 the 30 through 39 the
40 through 49 in every age group the
number of coveted hospitalizations is
approaching an all-time high
and unfortunately this delta variant
does seem to be far more disastrous for
younger people even for healthy people
without any comorbidities than original
covid
the disease is getting worse the virus
is getting worse it's continuing to
mutate and it's affecting people that a
year ago
if they got covered well wasn't a big
deal
or they may have even been asymptomatic
from it
that's no longer the case remember i
mean remember that last summer they said
well you know this is a disease of the
elderly or the obese or people with a
lot of comorbidities
not anymore
seeing formerly healthy people die of
this
we are seeing people come out of this
that may have permanent lung problems
as a result of this disease
and republican leaders continue to
whistle past the graveyard
digging in their heels and saying nope
we're not going to change what we've
already done because oh well then it
might make us look foolish
protect your citizens
i promise you you're going to get
rewarded politically more
for helping your residents than you will
for letting them
die
i don't know why it's so hard for these
republican leaders to get that through
their brains
but that's the situation we're dealing
with now
you can either piss off the minority of
people who are anti-mask and anti-vaxx
or
you can kill off enough of your base to
where you'll never win an election again
seems like a pretty simple equation to
me
i'm faring cousins and for david pakman
we'll be right back